SO THIS IS CERTAINLY A HOT
TICKET.
>> STEPHANIE READY REPORTING
FROM THE SIDELINES IN
PHILADELPHIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, STEPH.
YEAH, THIS IS NOT YOUR NORMAL
NIGHT HERE, JET.
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
IT WOULD BE EVEN DIFFERENT IF HE
WAS PLAYING.
>> OH, YEAH.
>> IF BEN WAS PLAYING.
I THINK THAT -- I THINK PHILLY
FANS ARE ANXIOUS TO SEE HOW GOOD
THEY ARE MORE THAN WHAT BROOKLYN
IS.
IT'S LIKE NO, WE GOT OUR GUYS.
WE HERE.
WE'RE GOING TO SEND A MESSAGE TO
YOU NO MATTER WHEN BEN COMES
BACK.
>> YOU MEAN THE TEAM OR THE
FANS?
>> I THINK THE TEAM AND THE
FANS.
>> NO, THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
THEM FANS HATRED.
THEY DON'T CARE -- THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THIS GAME AT ALL.
THEY'RE THERE FOR ONE REASON.
THEY'RE NOT --
>> HE'S NOT EVEN PLAYING.
>> THEY'RE NOT PAYING $4,000 FOR
NO REGULAR SEASON GAME.
>> THAT'S MY POINT.
IT WOULD BE EVEN BETTER IF HE
WAS PLAYING.
>> IT WOULD BE BETTER.
>> FROM A BASKETBALL STANDPOINT.
BUT FROM THE FANS STANDPOINT.
>> I'M NOT EVEN SURE -- DID HE
DO THAT ANY OTHER GAME?
>> HE DOES BEFORE EVERY GAME.
>> ERNIE, MY FAVORITE THING WHEN
I WAS PLAYING, I USED TO WATCH
IT.
I USED TO LOVE WHEN YOU SAID
THIS GAME WOULD HAVE PLAYOFF
IMPLICATIONS.
AND THIS GAME WILL HAVE PLAY-OFF
A LOT OF THINGS WE'RE GOING TO
BE SEEING IN THIS GAME.
JAMES, YEAH, I MADE A MISTAKE,
I'M NOT THE THIRD FIDDLE.
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU THE REAL
JAMES HARDEN TONIGHT.
KYRIE IS GOING TO SHOW WE'RE
GLAD YOU'RE GOING.
KEVIN IS GOING TO BE SHOWING
THEM.
GLAD YOU'RE GONE.
JOEL EMBIID SAYING I'M THE BEST
BIG MAN.
WE'RE GOING TO BUST YOU UP.
BUT IT WOULD HAVE BEEN A BETTER
NIGHT IF BEN WAS PLAYING.
I GIVE THEM CREDIT FOR GOING OUT
THERE.
I WISH HE WAS PLAYING.
I'M GLAD HE WENT OUT -- YEAH,
YEAH.
>> YOU PERSONALLY.
>> YES.
I WOULD HAVE GONE.
I WOULD HAVE PLAYED.
>> BECAUSE THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
CALLING YOU A COWARD AND EVERY
NAME IN THE BOOK.
HE HAD TO GO.
>> HE HAD TO GO.
AND I'M GLAD HE WENT OUT AND
GLAD HE IS SITTING ON TONIGHT
BENCH.
BECAUSE IF THEY DIDN'T, IT WOULD
HAVE TOLD ME A LOT ABOUT HIM.
>> LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT CARMAX
CALL YOUR SHOT.
AND SEE WHAT THE SIXERS AND THE
NETS HAVE BEEN UP TO RECENTLY
AND SINCE THE TRADE.
BROOKLYN 4-8.
SIXERS 8-2.
SIXERS ARE 5-0 WHEN EMBIID AND
HARDEN PLAY TOGETHER.
THEY MOVED UP TO THE NUMBER
THREE SPOT.
ACTUALLY, A GAME IN THE LOSS
CLUMBER THAN THE BUCKS, WHO ARE
NUMBER TWO, BUT THE BUCKS PLAYED
THREE MORE GAMES.
AND KYRIE COMING OFF A 50-POINT
PERFORMANCE THE OTHER NIGHT.
>> SEE, THAT'S WHAT I TRIED TO
TELL YOU GUYS THE OTHER NIGHT.
>> WHAT'S THAT?
>> WHAT MAKES THIS TEAM SO
DANGEROUS.
LIKE THEY GOT TWO GUYS, THEY
DON'T WORRY ABOUT MAKING THE
GUYS -- THIS IS NOT A KNOCK.
THEY'RE SO GOOD OFFENSIVELY, IF
THOSE TWO GUYS ARE ON THE COURT,
BROOKLYN GOING TO HAVE A CHANCE
WITH OR WITHOUT BEN SIMMONS.
THOSE TWO GUYS, THEY'RE TWO OF
THE BEST SCORERS WE'VE EVER SEEN
IN THE NBA.
THAT GUY HAD 50 POINTS.
AND HE IS ONLY LIKE -- AND I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW HE GETS
IN RHYTHM.
BLAKE, COULD YOU PLAY TWO DAYS,
TAKE TWO GAMES OFF?
>> OF COURSE.
>> REST.
>> NO.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT HIS GAME AIN'T LIKE
YOURS, THOUGH.
YOU LIKE GETTING DUNKS AND
LAYUPS AND SHOOT IN THE LANE.
THIS GUY IS DRIBBLING, DRIBBLING
AROUND GUYS, SHOOTING THREES AND
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
I THINK HE IS SO INCREDIBLE
BECAUSE -- JUST ANSWER MY
QUESTION.
COULD YOU PLAY -- I REALLY THINK
THAT IT'S DIFFICULT.
HOWEVER, I WILL AGREE WITH SHAQ.
YOU DO HAVE AN ADVANTAGE CERTAIN
NIGHTS WHERE YOU HAVE FRESH
LEGS.
>> FRESH.
>> AND THE OTHER GUYS DON'T.
>> EVERYBODY DOESN'T.
FOUR GAMES IN FIVE NIGHTS AND
ALL THAT.
SO IT'S HARD TO KIND OF COMPAR